want to get the one up and your
opponent's went ultra street fighter 4
launches this June Capcom community
manager and street fighter pro David
Hines gives us his tips and favorite
combos for ultras five new characters
here's what he's got to say about Hugo
even though he's really big and slow he
is really strong so he's got these cloud
moves which you can chain one into the
other that's a pretty nice combo but see
Hugo's got his command grabs much like
characters like Zangief and T horde but
he's actually got quite a few so that's
was the traditional kind of spinning
pile driver s special move he's also got
one which runs all the way across the
screen and the reason why this is so
good is he's now put the opposition in
the prime position it's um the corner
set up a gear now so they're now trapped
in the corner from here I mean medium
punch just collapsing from this far
brilliant he's also got one that froze
them against the wall this is his
strongest command round by far because
it allows them to follow up with
additional attacks right so from here
you can clap them wait doesn't in there
this is where it gets really interesting
if you've gone ultra stop this way it's
nice
look at the damage it's going to be
pretty good yeah I really like the way
this is animated the way it looks with
facial expression the way it slows down
that goes over the top so what I did I
did I use the half circle back and kick
move which froze them and then from
there I did quarter circle back and both
and two punches that's the e x version
of this crap because it uses the e x
version it then puts them into a juggle
state which sends them up in the air
again I'll show you another really good
combo of him there you go
oh nice pretty high damage combo de so
it was heavy crap into medium power into
like that standing like kick and in the
standing like kick cancels into the
super and then at the end of the super
you can cancel it into his back where
you go yeah it's pretty awesome